Peggy 18
it started back with the apex
corporation in the 70s and the birth of
Silicon River in North Korea even back
then their tech was way ahead of what
was coming out of America we bought
everything they could sell from phones
to tablets to just about anything and
when they started making weapons
well we couldn't resist
our wars in the Middle East have been
getting worse and worse one leads
straight to the next even after that
terrible day in Riyadh we kept fighting
as our country fell apart still we
bought a pegs to give us an edge as the
dollar tanked our debt to North Korea
spiral unemployment rocketed and the
country was on his knees the failing
government defaulted on the debt North
Koreans made their decision every piece
of technology they'd sold us at a back
door but they turned off our military
with a single button press
the first kPa troops on US soil were
said to be there to rebuild
but after the early eight packages it
was only brutality
they stole our liberty and our freedom
America is under control kPa
but she will rise again you are the
revolution
you